is it necessary to explain the why of
what you're doing as a leader if you're
not ever asked why my varsity athletes
never questioned anything as I assume
they're you think that I'll it'll be
disrespectful or because they simply
think they need to follow my directions
yeah they should absolutely know why and
people on your team do not need to ask
you why for you to tell them you should
tell them why they're doing what they're
doing that way they can lead that way
they have a deeper understanding of what
they're doing that way they know how to
act and what to do when you're not there
which you won't always be there and when
you do that they actually learn they are
actually learning how to lead themselves
because they start to understand the
importance of knowing why so you know
this this this this happens to me I mean
there's a lot of people that have worked
for me over the years that I didn't need
to tell them why to do anything well
they were ready to rock and roll like
they did not care I mean you think JP
ever looked at me and said hey hey sir
can you explain to me why you want me to
do that no he's like JP machine-gun nest
attack he's attacking like by the by the
time I get out of my mouth he's going so
there was no Reed there's no reason
there's never gonna ask me why you know
unleased not back then you know now that
we work together all the time if I'm
like hey I think we should do this you
say well why do want me to do that
because he's you know he's running ft
X's and he knows what's going on more
than I do so if I tell him to do
something when I ask him to do something
he might say well why do you want me to
do that what's the effect you look
around it so it's different now but my
point is much like a varsity athlete you
know that respects their coach and likes
the coach and wants to do a good job
well when JP was 21 years old he wasn't
asking me why to do anything and you
know for that matter that was that was
true for a lot of people that have
worked for me over the years like they
trust me and they don't they don't need
to know why they're doing what they're
doing they're gonna do it they're gonna
do it to the best of their ability that
doesn't mean that I don't
tell them because I absolutely shit cuz
if you don't know why you're doing what
you're doing you can't read
decentralized command doesn't work can't
make decisions in the field so even with
football athletes it's cool that they're
totally just on board but you should
still tell them why because it's a good
principle to follow in any leadership
situation yeah yeah especially as a
coach two men that'll like supercharge
like the learning process I think or the
training process like even like in
jujitsu there's good examples like it
like heip escape or shrimping right you
know when you first start or whatever if
you're just doing across the mat you're
getting taught how to do it and all the
stuff and you're kind of like I don't
really get why we're doing it good right
now you're glitter you find out yeah you
just do it cause everyone else to do it
what are you gonna do a new martial arts
class and you're gonna start asked us
actually I said well axel an example is
if you know why you're learning the hip
escape then you do it with better intent
and no one could tell just by watching
you do it whether what your intent was
or not even though they might get a
little sense of your intent but it's one
of those situations if you know why
you're doing it you're gonna do it
better just like if you're coaching
football and you got guys running a
certain thing they're not gonna ask you
why but if you tell them why they know
why they're doing it they're gonna do
they're gonna do it better yes so true
the football thing because in football
you do kind of some some oddball things
if you just see it on the surface
you know there's thing called grass
drills right where you just basically
you get your feet like you kind of run
in place real fast like kind of little
bit wider stance and then you like
basically you sprawl you know yeah and
you know you hit the ground you get back
up real quick and then you and they do
there's all these drills you do right
they face the ball this way then you
turn and then you come back and you're
chopping your feet a long time right so
on on the surface I remember when I was
like little doing that I remember
thinking oh yeah this is just like
conditioning really moving your whole
body conditioning getting back up would
but after a while you're like nah
because if you get knocked down which
you will like Praful you get knocked
down like three times and within like 15
seconds you know like the faster you can
get up and start running again
it's like bruh that's a good skill to
have you know kind of thing so if you're
drilling that every single day every
single day every single day not only do
you get better and quick
at that it becomes way more instinctual
so okay then there's a lot more to it
obviously but men if someone was
explaining that to you every time you're
doing it like even just yelling it out
just calling it out as it's happening
like good this is gonna get you guys up
quick when you get knocked down on the
label and you know just yelling it out
who cares whatever you don't have to sit
them down and say this is what you're
doing these guys you don't have to say
that necessarily I'm saying in a
football situation but if you're going
through that training with that in your
mind like oh I know why I'm doing this
bro you're gonna you're gonna charge
that thing and you know problem-solve
better while you train yeah man it's
yeah it goes deep unknown I said when I
was coaching a lot of MMA fighters I
would always be telling them why they're
doing a drill and look made me think of
when you were saying you know even if
they're just yelling to you you know
yeah I'd be like this is the end of the
round this is where you're gonna you
know yes if you're down here this is
where you're gonna have to get back up
this is where the fight gets one like
yeah you know cuz you know some fighters
if they get taken down and they're a
striker and they're going against a good
grapple if they could take a now they're
gonna have to get back up to win the
fight you know and so when they know
that you can see it compute in their
brain whereas if I'm just saying it get
back up ya know so tell people why